[Musique]
Annie jeune Var bonjour
vous êtes donc député du Doubs et l'air
et présidente par intérim de ce parti on
parlera évidemment de l'actualité de
l'autre partie un mot sur la réquisition
des dépôts de carburant Esso prononcés
par la première ministre hier vous c'est
bien c'est suffisant vous soutenez je
pense que ça arrive tardivement le
conflit sans kyste se durcit va
peut-être s'étendre si j'en crois les
rumeurs qui me sont parvenues et mais
dans un premier temps le gouvernement a
dénié la réalité comme il l'a fait il
n'y a pas si longtemps pour les masques
je vous rappelle qu'il y a quelques
jours Olivier Véran le porte-parole du
gouvernement disait qu'il n'y avait pas
de pénurie d'essence manque
d'anticipation complète
trois Français sur 4 en moyenne prennent
leur voiture pour aller travailler
aujourd'hui le pays est en place d'être
complètement bloqué
aussi totale photo réquisitionner ben
moi je pense que la fermeté
la fermeté s'impose naturellement et la
réquisition des personnels pour
débloquer les stocks d'essence et une
nécessité si songer que les soignants
les gens qui interviennent pour la
sécurité
les ambulances les camions de pompiers
et puis et puis tout un chacun qui a
besoin de sa voiture pour aller
travailler donc on peut pas bloquer le
pays à un moment où c'est déjà si
compliqué mais ça en dit long sur la
fragilité du corps social aujourd'hui
dans notre pays notamment face à la
problématique des salaires de gros
profits pour certains secteurs les
salariés réclament leur du
mais alors bien sûr les négociations
doivent se dérouler mais chacun reste
sur ses positions en plus la CGT dans
une séquence particulière puisque ce
profil dans quelques mois leurs
élections internes vis-à-vis de la
grande rivale qui est la CFDT il leur
faut montrer des muscles donc tout ça
joue aussi et puis l'opinion publique et
travailler par les questions
d'inflation de d'augmentation de
l'alimentation de l'énergie la grande
crainte de ne pas avoir de quoi se
chauffer et s'éclairer cet hiver enfin
on a là tous les ingrédients quand même
pour une crise majeure et je pense que
le gouvernement a réagi bien tardivement
vous savez les les crises sociales c'est
aussi c'est comme en politique c'est
aussi une question de nomade alors la
tension est aussi dans l'hémicycle hier
le rassemblement national a traité de
Bruno Le Maire de lâche est-ce que vous
soutenez le ministre qui demande des
excuses
moi je pense que si vous voulez tout ce
qui est insulte à tac personnel doit
être bannie de l'Assemblée nationale
lorsque je présidais les séances je
veuillais toujours à ce que les propos
restent
acceptables l'âge c'est une insulte je
considère que ça relève de l'inscription
au procès-verbal
la présidente le fera peut-être je ne
sais pas mais je pense que
on peut évidemment
c'est notre rôle attaquer le
gouvernement sur la politique qu'il
mette en œuvre le traité administre de
l'âge
ça relève de la taxe de la personne et
le propos était violent ça a créé un
incident de séance mais là aussi on voit
que l'hémicycle n'échappent pas à
l'humeur du temps qui est très très
belliqueuse très très éruptive le climat
n'est pas bon et je pense que le
gouvernement
à la fois le redoute mais ne sait pas
comment faire
le Parlement néanmoins de travail hier
la réforme de l'assurance chômage
proposée par le gouvernement a été voté
avec les votes de l'essentiel du groupe
les républicains pourquoi avez-vous voté
alors nous avons voté parce que pour
deux raisons d'abord dans ce texte il y
a la prolongation d'un dispositif qui
visait à raffermir les règles
d'indemnisation du chômage donc ce
dispositif tout ce qui peut ramener les
Français au travail nous le soutenons
dans le principe et puis l'autre raison
c'est que dans ce texte de loi nous
avons pu faire adopter un amendement
auquel nous tenions qui vise à assimiler
l'abandon de poste à une démission et
donc supprimer l'accès aux indemnités de
chômage vous savez que le marché du
travail dysfonctionne gravement
aujourd'hui il faudra durcir encore plus
tard écoutez moi je pense que
on voit bien qu'il y a un délitement du
lien des Français avec de travail
beaucoup de chefs d'entreprise le disent
difficultés de recrutement manque de
d'intérêt pour pour le travail c'est ce
qu'on a appelé la grande démission dans
les esprits et puis refusent CDI
exigences en matière de rupture
conventionnelle
stratégie pour alterner les temps de
chômage les temps de travail on voit
bien qu'il y a un dysfonctionnement
général du marché du travail aujourd'hui
les chefs d'entreprise
franchement ils sont dans une situation
extrêmement difficile d'une part ils ont
de gros problèmes de recrutement et de
motivation pour beaucoup et deuxièmement
les le renchérissement de l'énergie va
les conduire pour beaucoup à arrêter
leur activité moi je suis extrêmement
inquiète si on n'arrive pas à prendre
des mesures véritablement très
radical en matière de prix de l'énergie
récession et faillite sont là
[Musique]
vous allez en province en tout cas c'est
peut-être moins sensible à Paris
beaucoup de restaurants vous voyez des
salles à moitié vide non pas parce qu'il
y a pas de clients
mais parce que ils sont obligés de
réduire le service faute de personnel
ils sont obligés de fermer deux à trois
jours personnelles par semaine faut deux
personnes et donc là il y a vraiment
beaucoup de sujets le prochain texte
sera le projet de loi de programmation
sur les finances publiques c'est de
cette semaine celui-là le vote et vous
alors
la commission des finances ne l'a pas
votée puisque la programmation des
finances publiques comme son nom
l'indique
indique une stratégie
chemin budgétaire or tout indique que le
gouvernement
prend des décisions et des orientations
budgétaires soit qui sont peu réalistes
les prévisions de croissance les
prévisions de réduction du déficit nous
les jugeons peu réalistes et surtout les
efforts qu'il y a à faire ne sont pas
faits cette année sur le projet de loi
de finances de 2023 c'est 47 milliards
dépenses supplémentaires c'est un
emprunt comme jamais vu 270 milliards
vous voulez des économies c'est un
déficit de 150 milliards donc rien
indique dans ce budget et dans cette
programmation budgétaire qu'il y a
matière à approuvé les choix du
gouvernement donc si vous n'avez si vous
ne les soutenez pas il passeront par le
49-3 ça sera un rythmétiquement sur la
programmation budgétaire je ne sais pas
sur le projet de loi de finance oui bien
sûr vous déposerez une motion de censure
à ce moment-là s'il y a un 49-3 c'est le
réflexe d'habitude des groupes non ça
sera pas votre objet non et ce que vous
pourriez voter une notion de censure
déposée par d'autres non plus non plus
parce que voter une notion de censure ou
la déposer nous-mêmes avec
l'hypothèse la perspective qu'elle
souhaitait ça veut dire faire tomber le
gouvernement
Emmanuel Macron a prévenu que si le
gouvernement tombait et il dit solvait
l'Assemblée nationale nous venons d'être
élu nous avons été élus il y a quelques
semaines quel sens pourrait-on donner à
une dissolution de l'Assemblée nationale
que nous aurions provoqué par notre vote
les Français sont exprimés ils ont fait
un choix on le respecte je crois que la
dissolution et l'effet soit pour se
renforcer soit parce que il y a une
situation de blocage tel que vous ne
souhaitez pas le moment du blocage moi
je pense que le corps social est trop
fragile les difficultés du français sont
trop importantes l'environnement
international est trop difficile et
inquiétant pour qu'on rajoute une crise
institutionnelle et politique à toutes
les crises que s'apprête à vivre les
Français le maire de Saint-Étienne
Gaëlle perdrio a été exclu
officiellement de LR hier vous aviez
lancé la procédure il y a quelques
semaines il est en Pétré dans une
affaire de sextape de chantage à la
vidéo mais est-ce que vous n'allez pas
un peu trop vite par rapport à la
présomption d'innocence non la justice
fera son œuvre évidemment mais
le le parti se devait de donner un
signal fort à l'égard de quelqu'un qui
d'abord politiquement prenait de plus en
plus cette distance par rapport à nous
et se montrer cette équipe critique et
puis ensuite parce que cette exclusion
c'est le sens de nos procédures internes
a été demandé par la Fédération
donc
nous nous avons instruit cette demande
et nous y avons donné suite l'effet bien
sûr seront jugés mais tout indique quand
même que l'entourage très proche du
maire du Saint-Étienne était mêlée à
cette affaire lamentable qui a visé à
discréditer un élu un élu de sa majorité
donc les enregistrements sont assez
accablants il y avait la matière quand
même à prendre nos distances avec
quelqu'un qui dans les agissements sont
pour le moins
nauséabond LR est lancé dans ça sa
présidentielle interne échéance le 3
décembre pour choisir un nouveau
président il y a un mois pile vous
renoncier à briguer votre propre
succession à la tête du parti est-ce que
vous regrettez aujourd'hui de ne pas je
ne suis pas une femme de regret cette
décision je l'ai je l'ai mûri
je pense que les candidats se
multiplient
je n'étais pas sûr de la plus-value
qu'apporterait une candidature
supplémentaire il faut aussi quelqu'un
pour tenir la maison dès lors qu'on est
candidat on est obligé de se mettre en
retrait et là se poser un problème
fonctionnel et puis donc voilà un
ensemble de raisons qui ont fait que non
je ne le regrette pas et j'ai bien assez
à faire là avec la gestion de cette
compétitions qui sont pas autorisés pour
la grande question du fichiers alors
nous nous veillons sur les fichiers et
leur utilisation
de façon très
soigneuse et
c'est tout ça est très encadré par la
rgpd comme vous savez donc il y a très
peu de gens aux parties au siège qui ont
affichés qui ont les fichiers et on a
une très stabilité totale de ce qui les
consultent en revanche il y a des
morceaux de fichiers qui se promènent
dans les fédérations puisque chaque
président de fédération a accès à son
fichier donc après que des informations
soient livrées sur le terrain ça on ne
peut pas on ne peut pas l'empêcher puis
les les responsables politiques au fil
du temps constituent leur propre
fichiers donc ce sont des bouts de
fichiers agrégés mais quoi qu'il en soit
bon la compétition se passe bien une
candidate quand même jeté éponge
Virginie Calmel ça prenait pas de
problème de procédure en disant bah
toute façon tout est fait pour la
victoire d'ericciotti et la désignation
de Laurent Wauquiez comme on dirait le
présidentiel c'est jouer d'avance ou non
non pas du tout je pense qu'il y a des
candidats qui sont solides qui sont
sérieux qui font ardemment campagne sur
le terrain bon
pour l'instant ils sont 7 il y en a 7
médias voilà donc enfin les les trois je
dirais les trois plus connus retaille au
scioti
ce respect il ne s'attaque pas et c'est
une bonne chose parce qu'on appartient
tous à la même famille donc la
compétition est assez ouverte je crois
et c'est une bonne chose après il
appartiendra à chacun un de convaincre
et demain de rassembler le président a
annoncé hier que la France enverrait des
chars Leclerc en Roumanie plus si Canon
César supplémentaires en Ukraine vous
approuvez la stratégie du président de
la République alors bon je pense que le
Président de la République éclairé par
la vie des généraux a pris ses
responsabilités ce qui apparaît tout de
même c'est en matière de moyen militaire
notre grande fragilité
et sa justifie à mon sens quand même
qu'on fasse le point sur
les éléments qui sont à notre
disposition pour défendre notre pays je
rappelle que on est rentrer dans une
stratégie nouvelle qui est de se
préparer à des conflits de haute
intensité c'est un changement
stratégique majeur qui requiert qu'on
regarde exactement ce dont on dispose
pour se protéger Annie jeunes barre
merci bonne journée merci beaucoup
Christophe Barbier demain votre invité à
7h45 sera le ministre Stanislas Guérini